das unvermeidliche ist eingetreten
angela merkels vierte kanzlerschaft ja
im grunde wie fasst man das zusammen im
grunde wie bei der lindenstraße
stinklangweilig aber es hört nie auf
da können sie noch so oft sagen ein
weiter so darf es nicht geben
zum ersten mal folgt in deutschland auf
eine groko direkt die nächste gruppe ich
finde es verheerend trotzdem war die
vereidigungszeremonie im bundestag
natürlich das gesellschaftliche event
der woche hier also die kanzlerin in
weißem jackett ganz höfliche geste des
fraktionslosen herschenkt ein café ein
was daraus zu spät gekommen und hier ein
bild des tages die bundeskanzlerin nimmt
platz ihr mann der hier auf seinem
laptop irgendwas tippen frau künast hat
sich irgendwas im fuß getan
große auch von volker kauder also die
kanzlerin die sich noch ein bisschen am
hals kratzt juli irgendwas musste als
journalist halt berichten
tatsächlich gab es nur einen echten
aufreger bei der veranstaltung sie annes
die afd
nicht nur dass einer von denen seinen
wahlzettel fotografiert und postet sei
streng verboten ist der eigentliche
skandal war das hier gucken sie mal
bauland lässt sich minutenlang die
nebenhöhlen frei und nur sekunden später
drückte kanzlerin schloss ekelhaft
lügen presse natürlich hat auch diese
gruppe eine echte chance verdient so wie
all die vielen anderen groß vorher aber
selbst die hauptdarsteller schaffen es
ja nicht sich auch nur ein hauch von
vorfreude einzureden weiß ich wie es
eben geht aber ich finde ein bisschen
mehr euphorie darf schon sein
also ich freue mich für vor allen dingen
die menschen in deutschland die vierte
große koalition in deutschland ja genau
so ist
täglich wie soll das überspringen
ein bisschen zauber mit für den anfang
schon in nicht traurig wirklich alles
was die zusammenhält ist schiss vor
neuwahl
diese koalition hat alle großen
zukunftsthemen einfach vertagt es gibt
die grünen dass gerade noch mal
nachgefragt es gibt 15 neue kommission
zur rente pflege kohleausstieg sozialer
spaltung die groko stellt sage und
schreibe 100 fünf sogenannte
prüfaufträge verstehen sie damit man
jetzt noch nichts machen muss aus den
augen aus dem sinn
sie sind im grunde wie diese wissen noch
wie diese fertigen typen früher bei
peter zwegat die nicht mal mehr die post
auf machen
kennst du das wirklich kein schulbuch
fünf prüfaufträge total wichtige
zukunftsaufgaben und so müssten dringend
erledigt werden
aber du hast einfach keinen bock
krukow lass das mal irgendwelche
kommissionen machen
lima
er war später aber ich fand's ganz
amüsant dass frau merkel diese woche
sagt ernsthaft sagt sie möchte dass der
zitat wohlstand in deutschland bei allen
ankommt
leider enthält der koalitionsvertrag wir
haben extra noch mal nachgeguckt absolut
nichts was das leben von armen menschen
oder prekär arbeitenden menschen besser
macht aber andererseits für das ganze
thema armut hat sie allerdings ganz
sparen oder große aufregung diese woche
weil der herzlose lümmel aus dem
münsterland gesagt hat hartz 4 bedeutet
nicht armut der jens hat halt ganz
eigene ansichten auch zum thema
geringfügig beschäftigte die sind
nämlich auch nicht arm
meine mutter ist auch geringfügig
beschäftigt und weit weg von der
armutsfalle
es gibt menschen die nur diesen job
haben und sonst kein einkommen bei
meiner mutter kommen durch meinen vater
insgesamt noch andere einkommen dazu
insofern muss man schon noch schauen ja
es ist so blöd dass nur eine frau den
vater von ihren spahn heiraten kann
für uns wäre das armutsproblem in
deutschland bald gelöst jens spahn einer
der großen hoffnungsträger des neuen
kabinetts und ein weiterer sind wir uns
einig ist natürlich unser neuer
superminister horst seehofer ja horst
der islam gehört nicht zu deutschland
seehofer was der alles hat er hat das
innenministerium das bauministerium was
hat er noch ich hab das heimatmuseum das
heimathaus terium
ja
heimatmuseum passt scho heimat
ministerium oder wie sie es in berlin
schon nennen das forsthaus falkenau in
wirklichkeit kommen wir zu den fakten in
wirklichkeit hat die csu den seehofer
doch abgeschoben nach berlin
da kommt nur in die hauptstadt weil er
in münchen keine perspektive und keinen
job mehr hat im grunde ist das ein
achtung wirtschaftsflüchtlinge natürlich
kann und tatsächlich hat sich beim horst
in dieser speziellen angelegenheit so
eine gewisse bitterkeit eingeschlichen
so etwas wie freundschaft unter
politikern nein halt die fresse
[Applaus]
das wird super dass wir super horst als
innenminister der räumt jetzt auf in
deutschland ihr bams interview ich habe
einen masterplan für schnelleres
abschieben wow ja abschiebungen sind
zwar ländersache und scheitern in der
regel an sachen die ein
bundesinnenminister kann nicht
beeinflussen kann aber kommt egal wird
super endlich wird deutschland so sicher
wie bayern seehofer verspricht wörtlich
nie wieder rechtsfreie räume und viel
mehr videoüberwachung mit diesem
innenminister leute ist kriminalität in
deutschland offiziell abgeschafft